the Joe Rogan experience Chris Rock
walked out at the NW CP awards and did a
Jesse small angel nobody else is gonna
give you a CI you laughing look at you
enjoying that shuts different no other
comic is gonna give you that that's true
work what is the worst possible thing
that can be said in this room full of
black people that hold him and that show
secret yeah and he [ __ ] say it
outright to it you went right to it no
Kevin Kevin would have done that at the
Oscars Betty Murphy would have done it
you see Eddie Murphy when he did that we
got that he went after Bill Cosby it was
great yeah it was great what he's
talking about they're making him give
him back his awards like yeah yeah what
does who come back from it oh it's Jesse
small that you can't right yeah you can
come back from that really like people
are the most forgiving genre of people
art Kelly still sells tickets no he did
come back hard though that is amazing
but Kelly so the ticket time everybody
saw the piss tape he had supporters at
his arraignment in Brooklyn yes big fat
ones yeah black aunties so if you told
me just a small they can come back and
telling a lie on the street of Chicago
he say Canada's are Kelly it's not as
good as my caliber can get cast and some
Jesus movie in Egyptian in little
parallel and he's not admitting that
anything happened the problem is that
the people that could give him the
redemption are some of the people whose
trust you betrayed that's the problem is
that you started looking at the lead
Daniels and the Tyler Perry's and you
know maybe the ava duvernay DS and the
people that are in that world of black
cinema that could get them back in into
whatever this crossover mainstream world
is right so it's about earning that
trust again but I think there's no and
I'm just saying from personal experience
you know there's no group of people more
forgiving then I think Black
Entertainment I don't think they're ever
gonna forgive him for calling himself
the gay to part I don't think gay people
and that's for gay people to decide I'm
a Tupac fans but differently what the
[ __ ] did you just say yeah he's gone but
then you sit down on somebody's couch
you go yeah that was the old me and the
new me now and then you come out with
your wife you do some selfies on
Instagram kissing yeah but he's not
gonna have a wife boyfriend husband okay
fine whatever it is come out and be
happy and normal in some level of
patrician mmm-hmm but what have to he'd
have to like explain the whole thought
process for putting on the hoax why he
kept the noose on his neck lift goes
talking to cops while hold of the
subways yes you got to get drug through
the mud yeah come on now get this dragon
and get back to work and nobody's gonna
care 5-10 years or not nobody's going is
he a good actor I thought he was fine on
Empire my wasn't my cup of tea after a
couple of seasons but I mean is fine
show was entertaining well acted I I
never know I could looking at like some
self produced Netflix movie where I go
how the [ __ ] did this get on online he's
still saying that he didn't do anything
right he's still saying that he actually
got mugged I haven't kept up with it I
that's one of those stories where after
he got clear at the first time I quit
clicking the links and then the city of
Chicago started suing the city of
Chicago decided to sue him for the cost
of the investigators I hired him dead
yeah there's a certain [ __ ] I don't
click on any more injustice male stories
I just is he in a new movie that's the
only thing I need to know yeah I get it
I think I think I honestly feel like
there is a way back Marv Albert was
viable on the back wearing a dress so
there's a way back in entertainment
there's always a way I think there's a
way back for what's his face from the
the [ __ ] what's his name
the the Matt Lauer so way back for that
guy I don't know about justice Malloy
was lying on two Nigerians on the curb
yes
different layer matt lauer do my [ __ ]
up in the room you can't be just hitting
the job that's the narrative but
apparently all those executives had that
button they all had that button the lock
did they use it to grab to ass did they
like top ring that yes they did I bet
they did I bet a lot of them are
sweating out right now
oh they walk somebody in the room is
there a way back from Matt Lauer I don't
know if it is just a long room know what
the problem Matt Lauer's I was talking
about this last night no difference male
he knows he owned any of it here's the
problem
he doesn't do anything he doesn't do
anything that a regular person can't do
he just talks to people he doesn't do
anything he doesn't sing he doesn't tell
jokes he can't paint
so he's replace not making motorcycles
yeah what do you do sit that's so
awesome
he doesn't do anything that everybody
can't do everything he does anyone can
do he's talking to people that's all he
does is say hi I'm Matt Lauer with Good
Morning America or whatever the [ __ ] the
show was today today the Today Show
hello how are you he's just talking and
he's talking is the land and non-spicy
as possible but in the in the so you
think he's because they replaced him was
it was Carson Daly was that kind of who
they used for a while on today I know
I'm asking you I know you don't watch
the show that was on forever yeah let's
go like 1 o'clock in the morning that no
one watched but it stayed on yeah they
just said a morning show for a long time
too yeah
does like special he's been in a mix oh
no yeah that's making that up no no they
just matter of fact they just turn last
call over to a new host they gave it to
a Lilly Singh mmm so there's I don't
know I don't know what is because here's
the thing for there to be a path back
there has to be what is what does
redemption and ownership of whatever
you've been accused of look like right
because if you're and this goes back to
the whole redemption conversation is it
about your truth or is it about the
truth of your accusers or is it about
what society perceives you as bright or
the combination of those because if you
don't
if you don't agree with what your
accusers said to you then you're already
[ __ ] because that's part of the
redemption is respecting their truth
even if it's not true to you and it's
not what you believe happened and what
went down when you hit the child like
you did to the teacher correct
similar correct it's just hey I'm sorry
right
not great I don't know if Matt Lauer
would be saying that sincerely I would
sincerely look what can I do to show
attrition to move back because now even
if you've had that with the with your
accusers society at large still gets to
decide because the same ways society
decides who wears the crown I get to
decide to take the crown from sure and
any [ __ ] you can do about that right so
I mean that's in a [ __ ] up way that's
the game I'll be saved up enough money
he saved over money he made he was
making ungodly so I can go spin your
money just relax
go spend your money that's ego but
that's ego in feeling like I deserve to
be took it in so you get used to that
gig of being that guy who's on TV hello
good morning everyone
welcome to The Today Show today we have
Tom Cruise I'll never forget him and Tom
Cruise arguing over whether or not
Brooke Shields should take
antidepressants that's a real that's a
real clip so crazy yeah yeah they're
arguing over it it's so strange him in
Matt Lauer and Tom Cruise and Tom Cruise
is telling Matt Lauer he's being glib
you're being glib Matt you're being glib
because Matt Matt you know Tom Cruise is
like he's a Scientologist yeah and they
don't they don't believe in
pharmaceutical drugs they don't believe
in antidepressants or psychiatry there
it is right there there's a two of them
mark and Matt Lauer's got that I'm
thinking because I'm holding a pen and
pieces of paper war of the worlds'
that's early aught yeah it was a big
deal was a big deal it [ __ ] Tom
Cruise's career up for a long time
there's people like this guys are
[ __ ] nut what are they talking about
somebody else's business
he had talked about it publicly he had
talked about the mistake that she's
making by taking antidepressants okay so
yeah that's this and then that's all in
the game well